[Música]
los peces están en problemas la
población de bacalao de la costa este de
Canadá se derrumbó en los 90 la pesca
recreacional y comercial intensiva ha
diezmado la población del mero gigante
al sur de la Florida la población de
atún se ha desplomado cerca del 50% y el
atún rojo del Atlántico Sur está al
borde de la extinción Estos son algunos
ejemplos dentro de muchos hay sobrepesca
en todo el mundo cómo sucedió esto
cuando alguien piensa en la pesca se
imagina relajado en un bote recogiendo
la pesca del día pero la pesca
Industrial moderna la que llena los
supermercados se parece más a una guerra
de hecho las tecnologías que usan se
desarrollaron para la guerra radar sonar
helicópteros y aviones de observación
son utilizados para guiar barcos fábrica
hacia bancos de peces cada vez más
escasos línea líneas largas con ganchos
o redes gigantes rodean cantidades
masivas de peces junto con otras
especies los peces son arrastrados a
barcos gigantes que cuentan con
congelamiento instantáneo y plantas de
procesamiento todas estas tecnologías
nos permiten pescar en grandes
profundidades y Mar adentro como nunca
antes la distancia y profundidad de la
pesca han aumentado y también la
cantidad de especies a las que apuntamos
por ejemplo la merlusa negra ni suena ni
luce muy apetitosa Los Pescadores la
ignoraron hasta finales de los 70
entonces fue renombrada y comercializada
a chefs de los Estados Unidos como mero
chileno Aunque el pez Es realmente un
tipo de bacalao pronto el pescado estuvo
presente en el mercado mundial y ahora
es un manjar desafortunadamente estos
peces de agua profunda no se reproducen
hasta que alcanzan los 10 años de edad
lo que los hace muy vulnerables a la
sobrepesca cuando se capturan antes de
poder reproducirse El gusto del
consumidor y el precio pueden tener un
efecto nocivo por ejemplo la sopa de
aleta de tiburón es un manjar en China y
Vietnam y la aleta se ha convertido en
la parte más rentable del tiburón esto
lleva a Los Pescadores a llenar sus
botes con aletas dejando atrás millones
de tiburones muertos estos problemas no
son solo del mero chileno y el tiburón
el 31 por de los peces Sufre sobrepesca
y otro 58 por se pesca por encima del
máximo nivel sostenible los peces no se
reproducen tan rápido como para
alimentar a 7,000 millones de personas
la pesca también tiene un impacto en
ecosistemas más grandes los camarones se
pescan arrastrando redes del tamaño de
un campo de fútbol a lo largo del fondo
del océano que destruyen habitats en el
lecho Marino Por lo general solo el 5%
de la pesca es camarón el resto es
captura incidental la cría de camarones
en la costa no es mejor destruye los
manglares para ubicar las granjas de
camarones les quita a las comunidades la
protección contra tormentas y la
filtración natural del agua además de
quitarles a los peces espacio de
criadero qué tal darles un descanso a
los peces y permitirles que se recuperen
se los puede proteger de varias formas
en aguas nacionales los gobiernos pueden
poner límites a la pesca con
restricciones para algunos barcos o
equipos prácticas nocivas como el
dragado pueden prohibirse y se pueden
establecer reservas marinas cerradas
para la pesca que ayuden a los
ecosistemas a recuperarse por sí mismos
se debe concientizar a los consumidores
y realizar cots para reducir las
prácticas de derroche como la mutilación
de los tiburones y empujar a la
industria pesquera hacia prácticas
sostenibles hay muchas soluciones el
mejor enfoque para cada pesquería se
debe basar en la ciencia el respeto a
las comunidades locales que dependen del
océano y los peces como animales
salvajes y se deben aplicar las reglas
Por lo general se necesita la
colaboración internacional porque a los
peces no les importan nuestras fronteras
necesitamos eliminar la sobrepesca
ecosistemas seguridad alimentaria
trabajos economías y culturas costeras
dependen de
ello tenemos las herramientas y el
conocimiento para salvar el mundo Pero
cuál es el siguiente paso visite
ed.ted.com bar inclinada Earth School
para obtener una hoja de ruta que puede
seguir y medidas concretas que puede
tomar para marcar la diferencia